ce n'est plus l'affluence des grands
jours et surtout des grandes vacances
sur la plage de la française depuis
trois jours la baignade y est totalement
interdite
mais manifestement tout le monde n'a pas
bien reçu le message
capote et addiction il est où le panneau
le coach fait des choix bbc le premier
devait faut mettre un panneau c'est
souhaitable
il n'a pas cherché le en cherchant bien
on finit pourtant par le trouver tout au
bout de la plage les équipes techniques
de la ville intervienne car il va
effectivement falloir le positionner
différemment des populations bonne
visibilité par rapport à la qualité de
l'eau pour l'instant comme il est au
fond les gens pourraient laisser sommes
un peu trop loin car le danger est bien
là les dernières analyses
bactériologiques ont mis en évidence la
présence de germes indicateurs de
contamination fécale
les escherichia coli et les entérocoques
sont souvent accompagnés de virus et de
bactéries qui ne sont pas sans effet sur
la santé
les affections rhinopharyngées on peut
avoir des défis du site on peut avoir
des conjonctivites des otites d'aider
des choses comme ça et là c'est beaucoup
plus ennuyeux pour la ville de
fort-de-france cette pollution serait
due à plusieurs facteurs dont la
surpopulation de ces dernières semaines
avec des fréquentations qui a donné lieu
à cette augmentation
de bactéries dans l'eau suivies par un
épisode de mauvais temps qui n'a pas
amélioré les choses
c'est pour ça qu'il était sage de fermer
les plages à la baignade pendant
quelques temps les autorités sanitaires
souhaiterait d'ailleurs que les communes
balnéaires entre dans une gestion plus
active et préventive de la surveillance
des eaux
des études ont été réalisées pour mettre
en évidence les points faibles de chaque
site de baignade
le maire et ses services techniques
connaissent ces vulnérabilités et ils
savent que quand il y a une forte pluie
le marigot à côté de la plage va
déborder et donc à ce moment ils peuvent
prendre des arrêtés préventif
d'interdiction de baignade et à ce
moment là les baigneurs sont bien
protégés puisqu'ils sont informés au
moment même où la pollution est là ce
principe fonctionne très bien dans
certaines communes comme celle des trois
ilets mais d'une manière générale nos
eaux de baignade sont plutôt de très
bonne qualité sur les 1700 prélèvement
effectué cette saison la rs a relevé 30
et une alerte pour contamination fécale
c'est moins de 2%